So we are building something of this sort.
This one has two card layers that one has three.
And this one has two backs per layers double also.
Okay, that one also has okay. So actually it is this one.
It is this one. So this is the first convolution layer.
Okay. So this one it just has one convolution layer less
and one density or less. Anyway, the point is this.
we'll use the convolutional layers which are just
stack of matrices or tensors
to represent this picture in all of its three
color channels.
Then we're going to use a Max pool.
to
and something that is not visualized here something that is not plotted here
and not even there.
Is the kernel?
Let me double check that.
Do we have a kernel in here?
Yes, but it's not it's not it's not.
It's part of the convolution here. So there's a there's a matrix
inside kind of 2D layer, which is
called the the filter. So it's not visualize you
although it should have been that would have been more clear, but it's one
Matrix call involved with another Matrix and the
result of that Matrix. Well then be
pulled
inside this other Matrix
the idea here is to
contain the important.
activations from this Matrix
so
Let's keep this picture in mind. Let me take you to.
Vs code to show you what a convolution is first.